i'm here with our exercise guru ben
eater yeah i guess hell who who made
this exercise and now we're going to try
to work through it so let's see it says
what are the factors of nine you can
resize this box with nine dots the box
has nine dots to help you find the
factors yeah so what you're looking at
is you've got you've got these nine dots
on the screen and right now they're just
one row of nine dots and if you if you
grab that little thing on the right side
of the box and move that around to the
left oh that's neat you you still have
nine dots but they're arranged
differently and so what you can see is
is try to get them so you have the same
number in each row i see so this one so
if you have let's see not the same
number
oh three right there yeah and so so you
could get to nine by literally
multiplying
three
rows times three columns that's right
and you get to nine yeah so three is a
is a factor so three would be so and
then we would write that in this box
right over here so we would write three
enter all do we have to write three
twice because we have or is just writing
three one three three is a factor so
three is just put we don't have to write
it if we wrote it twice would be wrong
um yes actually it would okay so we do
mark that wrong you actually do mark
that wrong okay so it was three and
three but there was also right when you
started you had nine and one that's
right so so both of those are factors so
and i don't have to write these in any
special special order no no just one
gotta get them all and and i and i i
believe that's that's all there is and
we can look at the other ones and we can
see look two
two and eight definitely you know that's
not not working out
and it's interesting for people to think
about why these aren't working out right
yeah you can't divide two into nine yes
yeah yeah yeah and you can
that's pretty and that just goes just
one to nine again and we don't want to
repeat repeat these are the same things
exactly so let's check our answer let's
see how we're doing okay
let's see
there we go we got it all right let's do
one more okay let's do one more
correct next question
you can resize this box with 16 dots to
help you find the factor so one i'll
just it's one and 16. one and 16 are
factors sure so let me write those these
are all factors
and 16. so let's play with this box here
so yeah i don't know that's not working
that's not working
so i'm trying to figure out
so this is essentially going
2 times
2 might be a factor if i can just oh
look it is there it is
2 is a factor 2 is a factor
exactly exactly 2 rows of 8 works and so
we can say
two
and eight are factors
and if you think about it two and eight
both divide into sixteen that's
absolutely two divides eight times
sixteen your eight divides yeah you see
that you can construct these 16 dots you
can divide them into two groups of eight
that's right and i suspect also eight
groups of two well you can see
let's see so that's two groups of eight
really or two rows of eight
let's see
four oh look at that four times four
four times one and i'll just write the
four ones four is a factor four is a
factor
and then
i can and i've
probably seen i've already gotten eight
and two now i have eight groups of two
instead of two groups of eight but
they're still both factors then you go
back to 16 and one that's right so i
think we're done i think so let's check
our answer oh very good very good well
thank you that was that was fun
very neat very fun to play with no
thanks